if you don't understand certain things
Allah says in the Quran in Surah chapter
number 16:43 Andia chapter number 21
verse number 7 Allah says that if you do
not know ask the person who possesses
the message ask the person who possesses
the knowledge that if you do not know
anything if you do not possess the
message ask the person who's
knowledgeable for example if the Quran
speaks speaks about science who will go
and ask will you ask the cobbler will
you ask the Baba you will ask a
scientist because a scientist is an
expert in the field of science a
scientist is an Alim in the field of
science similarly if the
Quran speaks about medicine who will you
ask but naturally ask a doctor because a
doctor is an Alim he's an expert in the
field of medicine similarly if you want
to know something about Quran who will
you ask you'll ask an Alim who has gone
to dalum maybe for seven years for 10
years a person who's
expert about the nul Quran so depending
upon what field you want to know you
have to ask an expert in that
field so the Quran says that while
reading the Quran if you have certain
problems you can surely very well ask a
person who's an expert in that
field and that reminds me of the example
of prophet Kitmore there were a group of
Arabs who followed the advice given in
the Quran in Sur chapter 16:43 Andia
chapter number 21 vers number 7 which
says if you don't know ask the person
who possesses the knowledge
so these group of Arabs they collected
all the material in the Quran and the
Hadith which speaks about embryology and
they presented it to Professor Dr kit
Moore who at that time in the early '
80s
1980s he was one of the persons who was
the authority in the field of emology
and he was the head of the Department of
anatomy in the University of
Toronto so they presented the
translation of the way vers of the Quran
to Prophet
Mo and they asked him that what are your
commments so after going through the
translation the various vers of the
Quran and the Hadith he said that most
of the information given in the Quran is
in perfect confirmity with modern
embryology but there are a few
verses which I cannot say that they are
correct neither can I say they are wrong
because I myself do not know about
it and two such verses were the first
two verses of the Quran to be revealed
from chapter Number 96 verse number one
and two which
says read recite and Proclaim in the
name of thy Lord who created who created
the human beings from something which
clings a Lee like substance the Arabic
word
alak means something which clings it
even means a k clot of blood it also
means a leech like substance so
professor kmore said I do not know
whether the embryo in the initial stages
looks like a leech or not so he went in
his laboratory and under a very powerful
microscope he observed the early stages
of the embryo and compared it with a
photograph of a leech and he was
astonished at the Striking
resemblance and later on
when about 80 questions were asked to
him he said at that time in the early
1980s that if you would have asked these
questions to me 30 years ago I would not
be able to answer more than 50% because
embryology is a new branch of medicine
which has
developed
and he is the author of a very famous
book the developing human and whatever
additional material he
acquired from the Quran Hadith he
Incorporated it in his third edition the
developing human being and he got an
award for the best medical book written
by a single author in that
year and when I was in a Medical
College in the
1980s in the first year of medicine in
the subject of embryology if we wanted
to score high marks
we used to refer to the developing human
the book written by Professor Dr Keith
Moore if we wanted just passing marks
was to refer to the book written by Dr
inder
Singh you know just pass if you want to
score high marks then we used to read
the book developing Human by professor
kmore and this book later on was
translated into several languages of the
world and professor kitm said
I have
got no
objection in agreeing that this Quran it
has to be the word of the Creator
almighty God and Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he has to be the messenger
of this God
Almighty
whenever we purchase an
equipment along with the equipment we
get an instruction
manual for
example when we purchase a DVD
player we get instruction
manual which tells
us how the DVD player should be
operated if you want to play the DVD put
the dis and press the play button if you
want to skip press the skip button if
you want to stop press the stop button
don't drop it from a height it will get
damaged don't immerse it in water it
will get
spoiled all these details are given in
the instruction manual whenever you buy
an equipment
it has the instruction manual and more
complicated the machine the more
requirement of the instruction
manual if you allow me to call the human
beings a machine I would say it is the
most complicated machine on the face of
this Earth don't you think it requires
an instruction manual the instruction
manual for the human
beings it is the Glorious Quran the
Glorious Quran is the last and final
instruction manual for the human being
how a human being should lead his or her
life is given in the
Quran imagine if you buy an
equipment and if it is in the language
you don't understand and we know today
Japan is very
Advanced most of the electronic
equipment they come come from Japan but
when we get the instruction
manual we get it in the language we
understand there may be a Japanese
instruction manual along with it is the
English translation if you buy in India
you also get the Hindi
translation so when you want to
understand the
equipment whether it's a DVD
player whether it's a washing machine
you read the instruction manual in the
language you understand don't you want
to read the instruction manual of the
human being what has our creator Allah
subhana
tala what has he mentioned in the last
and final instruction manual of the
human being the Glorious
Quran we don't have to get it translated
it's already
available
previously when
automobiles were introduced the first
time in India people did not know how to
drive
so whenever you purchased a car the
company along with the car the company
also gave you a
driver once a naab a famous naab a very
rich
man he buys a car so along with the car
the company also
provides the
driver one day in the morning the
naab the rich multimillionaire he tells
his driver I want to take my my beam sa
I want to take my wife for shopping
please get the car
ready the driver replies
n the car is not in working condition
naab sa is very angry put the car back
in working condition immediately so the
driver says to put the car back in
working condition I require 10 L of
milk 20 kgs of pure honey 30 kg of pure
ghee and 40 kges of rice that also
basmati rice
soab the rich multimillionaire he gives
the driver 10 L of milk 20 KES of pure
honey 30 KES of pure ghee and 40 KES of
rice that also basmati rice top quality
the driver gives it to his wife and
within a few minutes the car is in
working condition
I'm asking you a question today if your
driver tells you that to put the car in
working condition he requires 10 L of
milk 20 cages of pure honey 30 cages of
pure ghee and 40 cages of basmati rice
what will you
do what will you
do will you give it to him what will you
do you will kick him out of the
job even though you're not a mechanic
you know how to drive the car you know
very well that a car runs on gas and
petrol it does not run on milk ghee rice
you know very well even though you're
not a mechanic you know the basics how a
car functions similarly today if you
know the basic message of our creator
Allah subhana wa ta'ala if you know what
our creat almighty God has mentioned in
his last and final instruction man of
the Quran no one will take you for a
you will understand your Dean much
easier no one will make a fool out of
you there are some people who tell me
that brother Zak suppose if you're
driving a car and if you have a
temporary
license temporary license is a Kaa
license in India temporary license and
if you have an
accident you know the police will give
you a small fine
if you have a permanent license and if
you have an accident the police will
give you a bigger fine therefore if you
don't read the Quran and if you don't
understand the Quran and if you make any
sin God will punish you less if you
understand the Quran and then if you
commit a sin then God will give you
double punishment you know very good
logic so why to understand the
Quran you
know behave like a person to have a
temporary life lons and enjoy life no
less punishment I told this brother for
sake of argument I agree with you that a
person who has a temporary license a
person who has a kcha license if he has
an accident
maybe the police will find him with
1,000 rupees or
$1,000 and if a person who has a
permanent license if he has an accident
maybe the police will find him double
2,000 Rupees or $2,000 okay I agree with
you but the point to be noted is that if
a person who has a permanent license in
one year the chances he'll have an
accident is maybe one but a person who
has a temporary license who has not
learned driving well the chances he'll
have an accident in one years maybe 50
so at the end of the year the person who
has permanent license pays a fine of
1,000 rupees or
$1,000 and a person who has a temporary
license he pays the fine of $50,000
a person who has the temporary license
pays $1,000 a person who has a permanent
license pays $2,000 so if he has an
accident once a year at the end of the
year he pays a fine of
$22,000 and a person who has a temporary
license maybe he'll have 50 accidents in
a year at the end of the year he pays a
fine of $50,000 or 50,000
Rupees there are some Muslims who go to
The Other Extreme who come and ex and
they say they're reading the the Quran
in Arabic it is not
useful Allah says in the Quran Ina
chapter number four verse number
171 do not commit excesses in your
religion to say that a person does not
benefit by reading only Arabic is wrong
there are various verses in the Quran
there are various Hadi which talk about
the blessings the Saab a person gets
even for reading Arabic
Allah says in the Quran in Surah anab
chapter number 29 verse number 45 that
we have revealed the vers of the
Quran and recite what we have revealed
to
you that recite of what we have revealed
to you of the
Quran and our beloved Prophet Muhammad
Sall Ali wasallam
said it's in Hadith number
2910 where the Beloved Prophet said
that anyone who recites one letter of
the word of Allah the book of Allah he
gets one Saab one H and that is
Multiplied
10-fold and Allah is not one letter Al
if is a
letter lamb is a
letter ha is a letter so you get 10 10
10 30 Saab for example if you recite Al
L me you get 10 10 10 30 Saab and this
is confirmed there's no doubt about it
but the amount of mistakes we make
throughout the day throughout the life
the amount of sins we commit are these
10 10 10 Saab sufficient to transport
you to
Jenna if besides reading in
Arabic
if we understand
in the language we know what Allah has
commanded and if we implement the
message of Allah subhana wa tala
inshallah you will get multiple time
Saab and Allah says in the Quran in Sur
Juma chapter number 62 verse number five
the parable of
those who were given the obligations of
the Mosaic law talking about the
Jews but they did not fulfill the
obligation
is the example of
donkey which carries tons of books but
they understand it
not Allah subhana wa ta'ala he chose the
Jews and he delivered the message to
them but they did not do the duty they
did not follow the instruction of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
so Allah says they are like
donkeys which carry tons of books but
they understand it not
and Allah says if you do not do your job
if you do not follow the instruction of
Allah subhana tala Allah says in Sur
Muhammad chapter number 47 verse number
38 Allah
says and if you do not do your job Allah
will subtitute in your place and other
people and they will not be like
you we Muslims we very often do Quran
you know especially in Ramadan we finish
the Quran once tce tce five times 10
times
alhamdulillah but most of us
Muslims even though we don't Arabic we
only recite the Arabic Quran twice
Thrice I tell them instead of reciting
only in Arabic the Quran twice and if
you don't understand Arabic recite in
Arabic once and the second time read the
translation in the language you
understand the best
if you know English read the English
translation of the Quran if you know Udu
read the Udu translation of the Quran if
you know Hindi read the hindii
translation of the Quran if you know
German read the German translation of
the Quran if you know French read the
French translation of the Quran read the
translation of the Quran in the language
you understand the best it will get you
more
benefit so that you can Implement on the
guidance of Allah subhana wa
tala our beloved Prophet M wasallam said
it's a Hadith mentioned ma chapter
number 16 Hadith number
219 by Abu may Allah be pleased with him
he said that the prophet said that oh
Abu may Allah be pleased with
him it is better that you learn one
verse of the Quran rather than pray 100
raats of
Salah the prophet said if one verse of
the book of Allah if you learn if you
understand it is far superior than
reading 100 raat Salah and every raat
Salah minimum that you have to recite is
Sur FAA minimum seven verses so in 100
raat minimum verses you'll recite a 700
vers of the Quran so according to this
Hadith if you learn and understand one
verse of the Quran and implemented it is
far
superior than reciting 700 words of the
Quran when we ask the
Muslims that why was the Quran
revealed many of us
say it was revealed for
Quran you know when we have opening
ceremony of office shop so we recite the
Quran when we buy a new house
housewarming ceremony we recite the
Quran when someone dies they recite the
Quran I do not know of any verse in the
Quran no say had in which the prophet or
any of the sahabas they recited the
Quran for the opening ceremony of the
house or the shop or when someone
died and they get a group of
people and they recite the Quran fast
you know maybe 30
people each one reciting one juice so I
tell
them that if you really want to do Quran
KH instead of that do Quran
family do it on this occasion no problem
do it once a month do it once a week do
it daily when you call 30 people instead
of reciting in Arabic one along with
Arabic even read the translation of that
ju which you have recited instead of 30
people call 60
people read half juw in Arabic half J
the translation which you understand the
best half family me understand the Quran
understand the message inshallah
inshallah it will get you multiple times
more I would like to give you an
example that there was a
person there was Indian who goes to
France to get a bachelor's
degree but when he goes to France the
language of instruction was French and
this Indian he did not know French so he
used to attend
the classes religiously regularly
whenever us to attend he used to get a p
p is for present full year he attends
the
class but the instructions are in French
he doesn't understand it after one year
he appears for the examination the
question paper is in French but yet he
gets a p p is not for past P is for
present but just by being present do you
think he will pass in the examination he
does not understand a word
maybe because he knows
English like how many of us we know Udu
script so we can recite the
Quran so he can read some of the French
without understanding because the script
of English and French is the
same do you think he'll pass in the
examination he gets the P the P is for
present it is not for
past that's the reason it's very
important that we read the Quran with
understanding Muslims we give respect to
the Quran alhamdulillah but many of us
they go beyond the limit they give so
much respect that they forget for what
purpose the Quran was
revealed you know we keep the Quran on
the topmost
Shelf alhamdulillah they keep it so much
on top they're difficult to reach and
the Quran catches
dust you the Quran is a book of guidance
it's a guide book you know suppose if
you are studying the guide book is
normally at a shelf which is
reachable you know it's kept at a shelf
which you can reach the easiest you
won't keep it on top very difficult I
take a stool to get it
down so Quran is a book which should be
referred every day it should be
handy and many of us Muslims you know we
tie the Quran in a pure silk
cloth and then we tie a knot on it so
suppose if you want to read the Quran
you start thinking okay 5 minutes to
open the
Quran 5 minutes again to tie the Quran
minutes the thought of you opening the
Quran and again tying it will be a
deterrent and if you have 10
minutes if you have 10 minutes time you
know to open the Quran close 10 minutes
better not read the
Quran see we have to respect the Quran
but the main respect is in the heart
I'm not against keeping the Quran on top
don't get me wrong but see to it that it
is
accessible it's easily available for
guidance you know many of us
Muslims before touching the Quran we
scrutinize a thousand things as though
it's an RDX bomb Quran wearing shoes can
I touch the
Quran can I read the Quran while
standing can I read it in the
office all these things they prevent you
from reading the Quran we scrutinize the
Quran as though it's an RDX bomb going
to explode the
Quran is a book of
guidance that the reason many of us
Indians object to you know the Arabs
mallah the way they treat the Quran they
give
respect but as though it's a guide it's
available we Muslims keep it on topmost
shelf you know in India it's catching
dust and rarely will we find people when
they are f minutes 10 minutes they ref
to the Quran because that you know we
have to have that frame of mind and then
we have to see 10 things we can't be in
shoes we can't stand and we have to have
a hat over your head etc
etc see many things are good but don't
make life so difficult that the main
purpose of the Quran is for guidance is
defeated and very often if you go to the
gulf countries you know many of the
Arabs when they come for Salah a few
minutes before you find them taking the
Quran and
reading in India
rarely will you find that and suppose
someone is Reading in the first row and
someone takes the Quran read in the
second row they'll be a personal object
how can you read the Quran in the second
row the back is facing the Quran
Haram and if you have to sit in the
mosque and suppose at your home in the
mosque if by mistake if you happen to
read the Quran while you're back facing
kah
you'll get fwa
Haram you know you can't read the Quran
with your back facing the back facing
the Caba I've been to Haram several
times in Makkah several times you know
they have this Quran they have the H
classes you know and the student sit in
RS many of the backs fa the Quran of the
other student who's carrying a Quran in
the hand and many of time the teacher is
facing the Caba and the students back
are facing the
Caba so where do they get this from
which verse of the Quran which Hadith I
don't
know so we have to love the Quran we
have to
respect but we have to know that the
main reason the Quran was revealed was
for hi was for
guidance once there was a Indian Imam
very good Kari he went to Saudi Arabia
and because he was famous it was M time
so they told the kar they told the Imam
IM you the Salah so the Indian
Imam he goes and he leads the Salah from
M he
decides and he finishes the Salah and
when he finishes the Salah one Saudi
Smiles at him so then he
asks that what's the problem was there
any problem in my
Kat so the Saudi told him no your Kat
was wonderful I was only one wondering
that when you recited Surah yusu you put
yuam in the well but before you complete
the Salah why didn't you get him out of
the
well this anecdote would be understood
only by those people who read the Quran
with understanding those who don't read
the Quran understanding will not be able
to understand this
anecdote the Saudi was telling
him if you read Sur Yu it speaks about
the story ofam that how he was betrayed
by his brother and his brothers put him
in the well and later on Caravan comes
and yam has got out of the well so the
Saudi tells him that you recited very
well but in your Salah you put yam in
the well but at least before ending the
Salah you should have bought him out of
the
well that means we
start the
Surah from anywhere and we end it
anywhere without realizing have we
completed the meaning or not
we Muslims we have several
excuses for not reading the Quran with
understanding and we always give
excuses for not
reading we have the time to read books
volumes memorize them but the Glorious
Quran which is the last and final
revelation of Allah subhana wa taala
unfortunately we don't don't take our
time to read the message of our cre
Allah subhana wa ta'ala
Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Muhammad chapter number
47 verse number 24 Allah
says do they not ponder over the
Quran or are their hearts locked up
Allah is saying that don't you ponder
over the vers of the Quran or are your
hearts locked up Allah says in Surah Bak
chapter number
two verse number
159 that Allah subhana wa ta'ala
when he makes the signs
clear after it has been revealed to you
and made the guidance
clear and if you conceal them Allah's
curse is on you Allah says Those Who
conceal the signs after it's made clear
to you and the guidance after it is
given to you Allah is curses on such
people Allah says in Surah fan chapter
number 25 verse number
30 mhamad Salli wasallam he says that
these are my
people who took the Quran for foolish
nonsense imagine the Beloved Prophet
mmah Al wasallam saying that these are
my people who took the Quran for foolish
nonsense but natur the context of the
verse is talking about
MAF but unfortunately
today we have Muslims who yet take the
Quran for foolish
nonsense the Quran was revealed as a
guidance for the whole of
humanity and when we read the Quran
there are two types of
reading one is called as Quran and the
other is Quran
T Quran is reading the Quran and
understanding the meaning
superficially which can be very well
done by reading the translation of the
Quran as well as the
Arabic the other is Quran is pondering
over the meaning of the
Quran thinking over the meaning of the
Quran this if you read the translation
it can be done to a certain level but if
you know Arabic as a language it is the
best
Quran can be done much better by knowing
Arabic as
language a person can say that he has
done Quran he has read the Quran but no
one can say that he has finished doing
Quran he has finished pondering over all
the verses of the Quran because the
Quran is
beautiful it is unlike any other book
that you read once it's finished if it's
a very good book you read twice Thrice
that's it Quran even even if you read a
thousand times the thousandth and first
time you read you get more
guidance every verse of the Quran it had
different angles to look at the words of
the Quran are
fantastic that there is a no human being
can say that I have finished pondering
over the ver of the Quran you can do
Quran but Quan the more you read the
more you Ponder the more you understand
inshallah the more will you
Implement every Muslim home should have
a copy of the Quran and if they don't
understand Arabic they should have the
translation of the Quran in the language
they understand the
best this Quran is the best gift you can
give to any human being irrespective
whether he's a Muslim or non-muslim
irrespective whether the person you're
giving the gift to is Rich or poor
whether it's a nikah or whether a
housewarming ceremony the best gift you
can give the most invaluable gift is the
copy of the Glorious Quran and if the
person doesn't understand Arabic give
the translation of the Glorious Quran in
the language they understand the
best the best gift you can give to your
child is the
Quran many of us Muslims we send our
children to learn how to recite the
Quran some of them may H the Quran but
very few non-arabs
s they make the children and they
educate the children in the language of
Arabic so that they can understand the
Quran directly very few the best gift
you can give to the child
is gift of the
Quran most of us including myself we
were unfortunate that our
parents did not think it important that
we should learn Arabic as a
language when we were children
don't make that same mistake see to it
that you teach your children Arabic as a
language it is the best gift you can
give to your
children it the best degree you can give
believe me all the the degrees of
colleges universities it may or may not
help him in this
world in the if it does not get him Clos
to Allah subhana taala it is useless but
if you give the gift of the Quran if you
give the gift of the language of
Arabic
inshallah because our beloved Prophet M
wasallam said that when a person
dies three
things yet get
him one is what he has spent in the way
of Allah subhana
tala number two the
knowledge that is spad in the way of
Allah subhana tala and number three
Pious children who pray for him
so the best gift you can give to your
children is the gift of the Quran it is
a guide for his full
life and we should make it a
habit that we read the Quran
daily whichever time you feel is the
best let's daily have a family
gathering mother and father along with
the children and recite depending upon
the time
available maybe two r
Arabic along with the translation you
understand the
best if every day you read the Quran
with understanding it will change your
life and also tell all the Muslim
businessmen that make it compulsory for
your employees to read the Quran
daily in Islamic Research Foundation
mashallah we have more than 400
employees in all the organizations
alhamdulillah it's
compulsory and every day when they come
the first thing when they swipe the card
or they put the thumb thumb print you
know the new machines Thum print and the
attendance ship takes the attendance
okay this is so and so he came to the
office at 10:00 the first thing you has
to do is read at least for 15
minutes at least one Ru two Ru of the
Quran along with the translation in the
language you understand the
best some people will think 15 minutes
every
day 6 days a
week 12 months in a year 400
employees calculate lakhs of rupees gone
down the drain every
month believe me it will benefit
you when your employees when they read
the Quran along with the translation
they will work better for you they will
learn honesty they will come on the
straight path
irrespective whether the employees
Muslim or non-muslim he will get in our
organization it's compulsory that you
should read the Quran along with
translation every day
compulsory I
request that all the businessmen here
who have got businesses and employees
seed that you implement it in your
business place also inshallah it will
benefit
you and there are various different ways
you can read the Quran from first page
to last
page secret you complete it at times you
may want to read it why the index you
want to read what does the Quran speak
about women what does the Quran speak
about heaven what does the Quran speak
about angels topic wise or you open the
Quran and read whatever comes the
various but see to it that you daily
read the Quran and even regularly
reading from cover to cover is very
important and since the talk is in
English
there are
mashallah more than 50 different English
translation of the Quran more than
50 and in our organization we have more
than 50 different languages in which the
Quran has been translated much more than
that in our organization we are more
than 50 different
languages in the English translation the
one that I recommend best is Abdullah Yu
Ali
amongst all the translations I've read I
feel this is the most
comprehensive
and he took approximately 40 years to
write the
translation and though his English is a
bit archaic me a Biblical e the da but
more closer to
Arabic in normal English when you say
you it's the same in Arabic
you know for you for female is different
for male is different singular is
different dual is different plural is
different six types an anti you know all
in English one youu whether it's a male
single or female single male duel or
female duel male multiple or female M
all six the same you shortcut so this
archaic English is more closer but it
may be difficult for the modern people
to understand but there are other people
who have made it easyd spef overall I
feel the commentary that he has given
and the footnotes and the index topic
wise I recommend for non-muslim as well
as for Muslim this is one of the good
English translations available the other
one is the international which has been
translated a few years back by three
American reward
sisters and the English is more
simple and it is more modern
the other translation is the noble
Quran byali and Dr M Khan but this I
would not recommend it to be given to
non-muslims Muslims fine because there
too many brackets in the footnotes you
have many Hadith you know bhari Muslim
which is good for the Muslims but there
are so many brackets that you fail to
realize who is saying that Allah or the
person who translated it so you give
footnotes no problem but if you give too
many blackheads you fail to realize is
this message from the translator of from
Allah subhana tala so that's the reason
it is good for references bukari Muslim
s but for non-muslim I personally don't
advise you to give
that the other fourth translation which
is good is by molana Abdul Maadi it's
good for comparative religion he give
references from the Bible give
references from the Hindu
scriptures it's in four
volumes the other one is
muhm Muhammad mm PA he a
britisher even that translation is good
but it doesn't have any commentary the
other one good is by Muhammad Assad
Muhammad this translation is good he
quotes very often
Zaki and he gives root words of Arabic
but you have to be careful zakari is a
logical T but sometimes it deviates from
the had you have to be
careful I normally prefer
translations which are directly done
from Arabic into that
language so English translation
translated directly from Arabic to
English are the best there are other
translations which are translated from
Arabic to Udu and then English like
Malana
M Quan sh they are good but the chances
of error is more because someone transl
from Arabic to Udu then from Udu to
English and that's what happened withi
translation and the second edition the
second translation by zarari is far
better so this was just a few
translations which I named there are
other by TB iring TB iring the
translation more of American English and
there are several other translations
before I end my talk I like to give the
message which Allah says in the Quran in
Surah hash chapter number 59 verse
number 21 Allah says that had this Quran
be revealed on the mountain it would
have surely fallen down in utter ruin
that means if the Quran would have been
revealed on a mountain and if the
mountain had feelings the mountain would
have crumbled
down and would have come down to Pieces
but to us Muslims it makes no difference
why because we don't understand
it Allah says that if the mountain
mountain is a sign of power of something
which is hard like a rock if the Quran
would have been revealed on a mountain
the mountain would have fallen down to
utter ruin but it makes no difference to
us we
Muslims we have to read the Quran with
understanding and we Muslims if you back
into the history we Muslims we on top of
the world today we Muslims on the
receiving and why the reason previously
we were on top of the world was because
we were close to Quran and say had and
today we on the receiving end is because
we have gone far away from our religious
scriptures far away from Quran and
Sunnah if we get back close to the Quran
and Sunnah inshallah we Muslims would
again become the TCH bars of the world I
would like to end my speech with the
Hadith of the Prophet M wasallam
mentioned s
bukari Hadith number 5027
of bukari in the old
Edition volume number six Hadith number
where with him said that our beloved
Prophet mam
said that best amongst you are those who
learn the Quran and teach it to the
others
[Applause]